beh gli attriti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono pari genio ci sono
tanti sul tardi deception playroom
deboscio treni 2 insulation il problema
è uno solo cento dei parti porco demonio
mi sono pagato
finalmente è sparso tipo di riprocessare
infarto brutto salve ho visto una luce
raga non sono pazzo ve lo giuro
ci sono delle piante brutte no raga ve
lo giuro su dio ho visto una luce non
sono pazzo non sono pazzo ma in tutti i
posti di me dove potevo svegliarvi non
potevo svegliarmi a gardaland i composti
lino o no non svegliarmi qua in tutto
sto casino sento dei passi fortissimi
stai zitta grazie più che altro perché
non lo vedi madonna che brutto però
mamma e vabbè non vale
e vabbè puoi vincere il suo gioco solo
nei prossimi update praticamente sono 18
prendono non mi ricordo come era l'altro
grandi ma era molto inquietante questo è
sempre abbastanza inquietante ma non c'è
un sito al polipo dal frigo devo
superare le robe con le spine ma porca
put e ne so io quando arrivano le spine
portico demonio
stiamo fuggendo da questo odio sento dei
pasti fortissimi e non capisco chi è ma
sono questi con che cavi incredibile non
ho capito cosa sia successo però vabbè
mi fate andare avanti chemical co
addosso stare qui
devo riuscire a girarmi velocemente non
sono morti io non posso giocare questo
gioco prima vedo luci poi vedo tizi che
girano speriamo di non trovarmi con
affare da un momento all'altro in faccia
tutta tua madre un tacco a madre morta
porca vacca stai fermo fermi fermi
[Musica]
col demonio porcia faccia mi sono
giocato solo ma che ca vedi io che però
tira le chiavi name a tua sorella ma ora
devo droppare tutto 18 riprendere la
stagliano perché sono rischio noti
mi scusi entro quale faccio compagnia di
origini si sta si sta bene qui e un po
pallido dovrebbe abbronzarsi un
pochettino stentata apra la bocca dica
no ai codici faccio la foto ragazzi
perché mi devo ricordare quello che c'è
scritto quanto ci fate che quell affare
si sveglia in 0,3 secondi c'è la croce
sul muro lavorista e io io non posso
giocare a questa roba lì non ce la posso
fa non ce la posso fare
ho vinto no no porco demonio morto
ricomponiamo ci devo andare di sotto a
mettere la cosa nella nella barca
l'uomo è qui no no non ci credo ma cosa
ci fai qua
aspetta aspetta per il colpo prendi
colpo il corpo per terra prendilo non
riesco a prendere i costi per terra
bologna porca [ __ ] porca via via via
via via piaciuti suo dietro c'è una
tizia dietro a 3
io questi giochi di merda però non li
posso fare quando è sera mi scusi c'è
posta per te va bene ma con quale
effetto sonoro del 1800 me lo stai
dicendo
labbra è allegro suo gioco beh mi piace
che pardon salve no no no no 62 liste
per di sempre inter per gli stimoli
vabbé fa niente
ho già sentito stormare la catcher in
the grudge porca [ __ ] io lo sapevo
perché l'avevo già sentito però non sono
stupido andiamo lo stesso andiamo lo
stesso lei già sentito sai che fa schifo
quello che succede non ci andiamo invece
no andiamo lo stesso va bene la mia vita
una vita da anni noti accovacciare però
non ti accovacciare non ti a commerciare
di non toccare
[Musica]
ok già parte bene
già la luce sfarfalla che una bellezza
ho detto già la luce star falla che
allora la mia pazienza non esiste quindi
volti nuovi treni all'ora ed aveva degli
altri inculati ma qualcosa mi dice che
non me ne vado di là la vita fa schifo
sono entrato alla porta chi la porta e
li riporta non si chiude non si chiude
la porta non si che la porta mi questa
ok ok che bp abbia via via via via via
via via via via via via via via via via
va bene va bene va bene va bene va bene
ok tutto a posto come se non stesse
succedendo niente fa niente chiusolo
agli ospiti comunque potresti tornare a
casa torniamo un altro giorno che dici
porca vacca se stanze chiuse mi sto
pagando di sopra la cosa brutta ragazzi
che tutto questo mi sono accorto solo
alla fine che aveva una persona
non come all'inizio che il prossimo il
campo per incredibile va bene trova
qualcosa da fare la tua vita
basta guarda i video viene contro te la
sveglia non la portiamo a guardare ai
sveglia sveglia
bye bye bye giu prima tu per favore
corrie è tutto tranquillo
chi è il perfetto arrivo e non è che era
un quadretto era come una patacca così
mario schifano in una delle cose più
belle che siano passate da telemark c'è
veramente incredibile ragazzi quest'oggi
siamo contro jason voorhees ricardo
milos che saluto 123 minimo timore prima
via tutto la maschera come nome ragazzi
un bug questo ma sono shrek ma ancora
non han dato che sono fuggiti si fugge
tease in due
riccardo milos è fuggito prima salta
madonna neanche incubi fai così schifo
e vabbè ho saltato l'ho saltato vai via
via via via papa niente sta crollando
tutto correri mamma mia ragazzi
originari sto gioco diventa sempre
peggio
potrò mettere una tarantella siciliana
già che c'eravamo noi
gesù non l'avevo visto non sapevo della
sua esistenza ed era meglio se non lo
sapevo porco il demonio come si uccidono
come si uccidono schiaccia e vabbè era
immortale immortale immortali mortale
non si sale più non ci sarà più
non ci sono no ragazzi io lo sto
giocando posso giocare non lo posso
chiamare guarda se devo prendere un
giorno di scenihr anni ci sono un sacco
di horror non so parlare
entra veloce che certi centro molto bene
perfetto perché è passato schermo intero
il video questo jobs che era talmente
forte che ha fatto dell'editing corri
corri maria sono morto sono morto non
sono morto non salta sopra è stupido ci
provavano giu non ci ha provato l'ho
visto dio la mandava i see that di una
scena in due mari di scrivimi su
whatsapp prima no stata la nostra eno
satana no satana non lo si nomina non si
apre la porta io ho provato aprirla
ho provato la prima cavaria così apre
sarei sempre che se quella roba da in
fondo vedo un tizio torna indietro torna
indietro lo vedo già lo vedo già non
andiamo avanti lo vedo già lo vedo già
cessata na li c'e stata una turbina
giovedì c'è un tizio torna indietro se
un tizio morto così che sta la torna
indietro per l'amore di gesù torna
indietro fai così indietro indietro
indietro noi andiamo avanti andiamo da
satana ciao
buongiorno io sono uno stupido io vengo
a saluta beh come fa lui come fa lui
farlo tu copia copia come ho fatto io
con chi vi pare dopo più di tre mesi di
pura vacanza e poi ricomincia la scuola
sembrerebbe davvero una grave mancanza a
guardare fantasma che vola
[Musica]
ma